pourquoi si longtemps ce que vous pouvez et ne pouvez pas dire
sur un panneau d'affichage
je suppose que vous ne pouvez rien dire de
diffamatoire et vous ne pouvez pas dire [ __ ] de pisse
ou de chatte ce droit ou anus je pense que tout ira
bien alors oh ouais je déteste son
père  c'est vrai
je suis Angela Hayes de cette manière alors Mildred
Hayes pourquoi as-tu mis ces
panneaux d'affichage ma fille Angela a été
assassinée il y a sept mois il me semble que
le service de police est trop occupé à
torturer les Noirs pour résoudre de vrais
romans policiers je suis dans le  au milieu de mon
[ __ ] de dîner de Pâques, désolé les enfants, je connais le
chef, mais je pense que nous avons une sorte de
problème,
fils, ils sont bien montés. Je ferais n'importe
quoi pour attraper le tueur de votre fille.
sortez ici en
pleurnichant comme une chienne est-ce que ce seront
probablement d'autres pauvres filles là-bas en
train d'être massacrées en ce moment nous avons eu deux
plaintes officielles à propos de ces
panneaux d'affichage d'une qui la dame était la
drôle je une dame avec un [ __ ] de
gros Dennis drôle alors  beaucoup de bons amis  est-
ce que ce sera dans cette ville avez-vous ah
j'ai dit bien sûr que je ne suis pas désolé pour
Angie mais la ville est complètement contre
ces panneaux d'affichage
Je ne dis pas ce que fait
Dixon quand elle vient te
traiter d'enfoiré,
nous gardons une affaire aux yeux du public,
plus tu as de chances d'obtenir c'est tout
[Musique]
tu sais si tu n'avais pas arrêté de venir à l'
église tu en aurais un peu plus
compréhension des sentiments des gens toute
cette colère juste ça devient une plus grande colère dans
trois deux
[Musique]
et aussi triste que puisse être le spectacle de ces
panneaux d'affichage ce journaliste car
on espère que cela mettra enfin fin à
l'étrange saga des trois panneaux d'affichage
mis un  fin de che [ __ ] de
retardataire c'est juste un [ __ ] de début pourquoi ne
mets-tu pas ça sur ton bonjour
Missouri [ __ ] de [ __ ] d'émission de réveil [ __ ]
[Musique]
toi